can get into it I do like him but that's
always the same Trope with like the
religious people it's always like the
ran through check and like the guy that
was a virgin that like marries her at
the end and she only really gets away
with it typically because she's hot so
which is yeah that's a fair
representation
it happened like I use a nice
I'm saying like that's what he said I
mean I don't I don't know like I'm not
trying to make it a personal thing but
wait can I can I finish basically like
that's what like the wife goes up first
and she talks about how she was like
slept with all these people and then the
guy goes up and talks about how he did
it and then the girl like gets married
at the end and yeah that's it's always
the same thing like so the girl
basically gets ran through and then the
guy marries her after and I'm like it's
kind of selling dreams and like an
attractive girl can get away with it but
like the average check it's like